I'm about to go to Buckingham Palace to
tender my resignation to Her Majesty the
Queen and to advise her to ask Boris
Johnson to form a new administration I
repeat my warm congratulations to Boris
on winning the conservative leadership
election I wish him and the government
he will lead every good fortune in the
months and years ahead their successes
will be our country's successes and I
hope that they will be many their
achievements will build on the work of
nearly a decade of conservative or
conservative-led government during that
time our economy has been restored our
public services reformed and our values
defended on the world stage of course
much remains to be done the immediate
priority being to complete our exit from
the European Union in a way that works
for the whole United Kingdom with
success in that task can come a new
beginning for our country a national
renewal that can move us beyond the
current and pass into the bright future
the British people deserve to serve as
Prime Minister of the United Kingdom is
the greatest honor the heavy
responsibilities are outweighed by the
huge potential to serve your country but
you achieve nothing alone and as I leave
Downing Street my final words are of
sincere thanks to my colleagues in
government and Parliament to everyone in
the building behind me and across the
civil service to the men and women of
our armed forces and security services
and to the public servants in our
schools our NHS our police and the other
emergency services all are inspired by
the noble wish to serve their country in
the national interest I also want to
thank the British people everyone who
loves our great country who works hard
for their family
and wants their children and
grandchildren to enjoy greater
opportunity than they did thank you for
putting your faith in me and giving me
the chance to serve
this is a country of aspiration and
opportunity and I hope that every young
girl who has seen a woman Prime Minister
now knows for sure that there are no
limits to what they can achieve finally
and most of all I want to thank my
husband Philip who's been my greatest
supporter and my closest companion I
think the answer to that is I think not
I'm about to leave Downing Street but
I'm proud to continue as the Member of
Parliament for Maidenhead I will
continue to do all I can to serve the
national interest and play my part in
making our United Kingdom a great
country with a great future a country
that truly works for everyone for the
last time
they can be moved to one side waving
goodbye though mrs. may not even I
believe in the middle of that speech
when the exact thing he goes around
Westminster crying stop drugs it
interrupted her speech and she said I
think the answer the answer to that is I
think not I said mrs. make fully
confident that Greg's if this doesn't
happen then it's going to be parcel the
project or a navy exits policy by
success by responsibly half the city now
okay without husband to the black Jaguar
which will return in an hour or so very
another Prime Minister Boris Johnson
that this is prime minister to resume
saying goodbye to Downing Street which
is been our home for the past three
years and a few days